Margaret what is something about nuns
faith anything relevant to the film that
you didn't know I think well I'm not
really religious I'm not really just in
life I think I'm spiritual but I'm not
Christian by any means and so it gave me
an opportunity to to learn about
Catholicism and you know read the Bible
for the first time and then there was a
lot about being none that I just had no
idea where you know as far as like
writing by all of the rules in place to
limit any sort of extraneous stimulation
like custody of the eyes and not being
able to touch anybody and not being able
to talk freely ever
and ideally communicating through sign
language and you know not talking at all
during grand silence all of these things
were foreign to me and much more extreme
than I anticipated but yeah Maggie for
you what was that what like what
something I learned that I didn't yeah
for the process I mean no you read a lot
of nun BIOS all right yeah yeah I mean I
think I think the biggest biggest
biggest thing that you learn which may
come across as like the simplest and the
most obvious too is like that nuns are
extremely complex complicated women with
lots of layers to their personalities
lots of internal struggles I think even
the the image of nuns that we have in
society it's kind of this very
one-dimensional like like just almost
like like a like an image not a person
and what you know what I learned from
reading it's like these are really
complicated women like that are dealing
with like really complicated day and day
out struggles you know you know the same
as every woman I know
another thing that Maggie talks about a
lot is about how literal their
relationship is between nuns and God and
that's something that I was unaware of
as well I didn't realize I think what
was so exciting about this project was
the opportunity to have you know God be
my boyfriend
essentially you know I've shown it if
you like first love and
in the moments where Kathleen's praying
she wants it to be like I was talking to
my boyfriend in bed with me and I didn't
realize that nuns felt so passionately
about we knew obviously they'd felt
passionate but I didn't realize that it
was as romantic as it is do you think
faith today in and outside of the church
is stronger in today's culture or not as
strong it depends what you define faith
as I mean there are today in the United
States for example there are more people
who identify as more people who didn't
who do not identify with any religious
background but do identify a spiritual
and that population is increasing and
increasing increasing and the population
of people who feel attached the attacks
are identity to an organized religion is
decreasing so I think that like I don't
think there's I think like seeking like
some sort of connection or sense of
something larger it's like absolutely
like embedded within like the human DNA
it's like a huge part of the human
condition but the but I think people are
questioning whether they need the
institution and the organization as much
anymore I know you studied a lot of
books or you read a lot of books on nuns
that had left either the church maybe
they kept with their faith what was some
of the the similarities that you saw
that you took away with from some of
these nuns and their experiences post
yeah well they were anything they had
they had exactly the same thing that I
was just saying before they had let go
of their relationship with the church
but what they described is this sort of
place of a spiritually evolved thing
that they developed within themselves
was so beautiful and so calm and at
peace and without all the agitation and
the and the anxiety that they had an
initiate or with in terms of their
relationship with the church but that
came through a lot this kind of like
very spirituality was still a huge part
of their life but they they left the
church behind long sense
you